you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum oh-ryun tastes how are
you bud
good Happy New Year happy New Year to
you we did the best of 2019 last week it
was it was great I really liked it Thank
You Mia for putting that together I know
it wasn't easy and Brice you guys worked
hard to get that all figured out but we
hadn't done something like that and
people do that and I thought it'd be fun
to do a top 13 and you know it was fun
it was fun yeah we figured it out right
yeah me I figured it out
but hey look I want to say hello shout
out to everybody that keeps supporting
the show the patrons the patrons I love
you guys thank you for subscribing and
you know giving your money to a show
that you love and you believe in and
that means a [ __ ] ton more than you
could possibly imagine you know it's
been a good year so far look it's just
started a lot of good stuff coming up
with with the podcast got some great
guests really great guests and we're
doing the video we're going to
transition into video and I hope that
works I hope that gives us a bigger even
a bigger audience and you know it's it's
worth a shot isn't it Ryan I think so
all the kids are doing it and the show
won't lose anything other than you could
still listen to it on all your platforms
and then you could also watch it
probably on YouTube at some point
correct indeed indeed so uh I will be in
Portland with Tom Welling my cohort on
January 24th for the wizard con or
whatever so get your tickets we're doing
a Smallville Knights we did the improv
show so get your tickets go to wizard
worldcom you'll figure it out go on my
twitter or whatever also be in Mexico
March 13th
yeah that whole weekend Tom and I will
be there we're finally going to Mexico I
know we have a lot of Mexican friends
and I'm excited about that I love I love
Spanish I love learning Spanish which
I'm not great at I love people speaking
Spanish it's great language it's easy to
listen to
although sometimes I think people are
fighting when they're just having a
conversation yeah you know it's lively
it's lively it's a lively fun
conversation where you going to Mexico
Mexico City for the for their comic-con
or whatever so Tom and I will be over
there for three days it's going to be
great so make sure you sign up for that
and
check out our little improv show you're
not gonna want to miss it
thank you for supporting the podcast on
Instagram make sure you keep that up
it's inside of you at inside of your
podcast on Instagram Twitter at inside
of you pod thank you for supporting the
band left on Laurel if you want any
merch and go to the inside of your store
and get merch therefore inside of you or
what Sun Laurel also wants you guys to
know that pure evil the wine that we do
with knocking point wines I knew there's
subscriptions available we did a new one
I'm the pure Wellings the evil now and
you can get that go to knocking point
calm use my code which you'll just look
on Twitter Instagram you get a discount
on that on the subscription but it's
badass we sold that last year and I'm
pretty sure gonna salt this year so so
that's pretty much that you know this
guest today I just like I like that he
likes me you know you want to be liked
and I feel like this guest is someone
who you know probably gets asked to do
tons of interviews and Stephen Amell and
he gets you know but he we had a
connection I don't know what it was the
first episode he says I like your
questions I like your the way you handle
interview and I was like wow this is
great and he came back and I must have
caught him at a crazy time I did catch
him at a crazy time Ryan and you were
here and he was talking about life and
he just seemed like he was just
finishing up season 8 of arrow his final
season he looked a little tired still
gorgeous still gorgeous
and I I could just tell something was a
little off and he was more emotional he
made it very clear that he was just very
tired he had just had it like you know I
can't even imagine I'm single guy here
and you know life kid back and forth
Vancouver you're the lead you're holding
it you're constantly doing fight scenes
because he loves to do his own fight
scenes yeah I think you look at him you
think this is just the perfect human
being the perfect specimen this is like
the Yvonne Drago and rocky 4 but things
start to unwind in the first half of
this interview let's just say things get
interesting I wasn't surprised as much
as Ryan was Ryan was a little
you were nervous you didn't you know you
need to know what to do you had an
experienced people like sort of he was
falling apart like right in front of us
yeah was falling apart a little bit and
I think he was just trying to keep it
together I don't know why he showed up
for the podcast and I kept being I joked
with him in the second half of this
interview but you'll hear about all of
it and I'm glad that he was a sport and
you got to hear the before and after so
this is a two-parter so um let's get
into it it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you with Michael
rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you're just looking at a
picture of the first X amount of guests
I had on the show and you're one of them
the only three people have come on twice
that's you hat exact Levi and Tom
Welling that's it and you live so close
you could come really every day if you
want do you want me do you think we'd
run out of [ __ ] to say maybe I don't
know I think just in the kitchen now we
could probably had a conversation for a
good four minutes when did you move up
from the COS last time we did this we
were down in the basement yeah you know
I wanted it to be a little more intimate
but the real reason was I felt like all
that [ __ ] had to be put out guests would
come and then not that I would have to
put it back but I put some of it back
sure right so I felt like I had to move
everything here you just walk in you're
ready to go yep though what do you think
you like this do you feel claustrophobic
I'm mostly worried about keeping my
keeping as close to the microphone as
possible yeah that's and that's
important there we go and now it's your
drifting for is it burps you don't sorry
I burp - I burped in the last puckish
you don't do many podcasts I haven't
done a podcast since I did your podcast
is that true no you did you did one you
did Anna Faris at the time oh because
that's when you told her that I was one
of the best podcasts out there I just
wanna I just remember that yeah but that
was like I'd like to doing it but that
was a requirement that was a Comicon
thing oh the honor Ferris was yeah so
his father was nice but it was you
didn't want to do it required I was and
I wasn't different I wouldn't have I
wouldn't have seeked it out I remember
specifically wanting to do your podcast
really uh-huh
why is that we didn't really know each
other but why did you want to do my
podcast because you think you're pretty
[ __ ] good at the I like the
interviews you seem to get people to
share stuff that they wouldn't
necessarily share right I'm a little I'm
a little frightened you don't need to be
frightened you really don't need to be
frightened it's just there's so much to
talk to you about and I you know I you
know I had just print all this stuff out
but I didn't look at it because it
doesn't really matter I know enough
about you but you're interesting and I
will tell you this this is completely
not
sequitur my friend Troy he he said
something then enough I told you about
but he's like yeah you know I heard
Stevens a little intense on the arrow
set or this was years ago this is many
years ago and you I think you discussed
this yeah like yeah yeah I don't know is
is he a nice guy or like he listened to
the podcast oh and said boy was I wrong
this guy's awesome you know when I
started arrow like and we talked about
this before I definitely gripped a
little bit too tight you know like noise
on set phones you know anxious to you
the lead it's a new thing I wasn't I
also you know relatively speaking wasn't
as mature and that really changed around
season 3 and yet I wore that [ __ ]
reputation until until we finished the
show
yeah you hey you ever hear if you ever
hear you will never hear a bad thing
about me from the arrow crew never from
cast ever never my reputation is rumor
and innuendo that's that that's what I'm
getting at it is not deserved and in it
[ __ ] pisses me I know it does and
that's why I knew I could bring it up to
you
yep because I know you and I know what
it's like to be on set for hours upon
hours and the the pressure in my theory
is that if you um somebody says oh I met
this one actor on the street and he was
kind of rude I'm like do you think maybe
you had a bad day yeah I never I never
believed that [ __ ] you always give the
better now if people a person after
person start coming up it's always one
guy one story that sort of evolves I
have never ever treated anyone that I
work with with anything less than the
utmost respect Katherine McNamara I'm
gonna tell you this now I interviewed
her and I think yours is gonna air
before hers but it doesn't matter okay I
asked her I didn't ask for anything
about you really other than you know
just regular [ __ ] you know you're her
dad on the show yeah that's true but I
said I said who's your favorite cuz oh I
don't want I don't know no no no who's
your food you like look really look
forward to working with every day it
could be many people just throw the
first person that comes to your mind she
has Steven she said Steven
did she not Ryan you were there was an
hour ago it wasn't an hour ago I
remember it well how does that make you
feel makes me feel good very very aware
that there's only so much about your
reputation that you can control I just
know that that everyone that everyone
that worked on arrow cast and crew when
we announced that it was going to be the
final season and that we were gonna be
ten episodes every single show in
Vancouver immediately tried to hire our
crew like by going well you're you're
only gonna do ten episodes come with us
do 22 they stayed everyone stayed cuz I
asked them to and I feel like I earned
it I [ __ ] love that yeah and you say
that with conviction you you believe it
cuz you know it you know it to be true I
would say the same thing
Catherine said something nothing we're
gonna toot our own horn but [ __ ] it
she's like you know oh my god I was
talking to JT and I was talking to
so-and-so and my other crew when we're
doing Shadowhunters and this and they
all knew you and they all were telling
stories like oh [ __ ]
or are they saying they're like no they
all admired you Mike what how would Troy
ever he where's Troy KITT he's throwing
that and from yeah I'm just curious as
to where he's getting his information at
some you know that I mean well that's
the thing I think he was um doing extra
work on arrow okay
he's look he's a great guy I love you
Troy he knows that I'm a nerd but he's
nerd stirr'd honest okay this guy is a
guy he dresses up to do Renaissance
shows I love it I think it's great he's
he's a great friend he's smart he's a
good actor years ago he was an extra or
something and I think somebody said
something or somebody you know people
gossip people talk but he didn't say you
were a bad guy he just said yeah I
wonder what he's like in you know in
person because I you know it seemed like
maybe there was some difficulty early on
sure yeah early on it was a little I was
a little quick tempered but I don't take
any of it back
what drives you crazy what like upsets
you that you know is warranted that's
worthy of like you know what let me
guess probably when you're walking on
set and now you're waiting 30 minutes
when they said there
to shoot I probably bothers this [ __ ]
out he does it really does especially
when you're the lead actor on the show
like I said before I I I spoke to that
like you know to a man I spoke to the
crew you know early on it's like do you
guys want to break for 15 minutes every
day and talk about our feelings or do
you want to get this [ __ ] done cuz we
just have to come back the next day
right and I know this is true I did
annoy the crew right because I had this
encyclopedic knowledge of the show and
if we were doing something and it didn't
track it didn't match up it didn't fit
with continuity I would put my foot down
until we got it right uh-huh
see we're getting some and so but here's
what would happen 20 different times a
crew member has come up to me and gone
you know it's really [ __ ] annoying
when you do that but you know what's
most annoying about it I go No and I go
you're always [ __ ] right so we it's
like it's annoying but we begrudging Lee
accept that you're doing it in servitude
to the show and I believe that
wholeheartedly I'm never that guy which
is probably annoying in the other way I
go the opposite direction where I'm like
you know what do you mean an example I
was playing there's an episode where I
play Zod Yeah right
and I remember two Welling I go guess
what bro he's like why I go guess who's
getting paid twice on this episode he's
like who me he's like why I'm playing
Lex I'm playing odd they paid you twice
no no and on top of it
I saw Christopher Walken on some
talk-show and he goes yeah I don't read
scripts you're gonna find out what
happens anyway my scenes had nothing to
do with Tom it really hadn't I didn't
need to know anything about his world
because not knowing other than what I
was supposed to know as the character
yeah so my character came in I want a
lot of times I didn't know was going on
yeah but you read every script every
script well your arrow yeah you have to
I didn't have to do that but if I'm
reading every script in you but you went
above because you you learned everything
there was to know about Oliver Queen and
in the universe curse right yep so you
would say things like what's something
that in retrospect annoyed someone that
you said something that you can remember
that you go now
Oliver wouldn't say that or do that or
wear that what was it I can't remember
any specific instance but I'd actually
have the script supervisor they would
come asking me questions they'd be like
hey what happened I'll go in season two
in episode 13 this person said this to
another person that's why we can't do it
the way that's written and you need to
make a change you're that aware yeah
are you that I think that takes a
certain brilliance though doesn't it
I mean but is it or is that just you're
so aware and you're so disciplined and
you're so and you have a good memory
I have a [ __ ] memory with regular stuff
like I forget stuff all the time I'm
terrible with people's names what's my
last name
Rosenbaum kai remember his name you
almost said a Craig Craig Creek
Chris Ryan yeah Pok I didn't say any I'm
that girl Dan they met him once it was
quick yeah and by the way last time
there was another dude sitting there
yeah that's not your fault yeah it still
bugs me do you cry I mean I know you cry
probably when your kid was born you
probably cried at your wedding I've
cried twice today what you're a liar
I'm not lying you cry I'm worried that
I'm gonna cry during this podcast do you
not that cry but if you cry you're
comfortable because you know me I don't
you I cry you know I cry yeah you know
but tell me what you cried about today
um I have really really been struggling
with the end of the show I'm mentally
exhausted and my wife forced me to go to
the force me to go to the doctors say
because she was she was worried that
something was was actually wrong with me
and I said that thing is wrong with me
I'm just tired I'm like I don't want to
go to the doctor she got really mad at
me and she told me to get my [ __ ]
together and that really it set me off
because I was I was yeah I was literally
sitting on the ground did I've gone down
a couple of times over the past few
weeks down down down to a dark place
yeah couple weeks ago I spent
my family was going out to Palm Springs
and I just hooked my wife and I'm like I
can't even get myself off the ground
right now laid on the couch for two days
didn't eat I'm in a state of mourning
and it's really tough I also feel as
though I need to mentally reset if I
could if I could if I could do it again
I wrapped arrow on the 15th of November
if I could do it again I would have
absconded with my family I'd be in
Africa right now on safari with no phone
I just feel like I've been trying to do
things for people for the past for the
past eight years and I just need a
[ __ ] break I want to be a dad I want
to be a husband I don't even really want
to talk to my friends that much I just
need a break and I and I and I cried
about it twice today just randomly
mm-hmm yeah and I still don't like
crying in front of my wife that much
there's something about it that that
feels emasculating that'sthat's stigma
that's this yeah I know I'm wrong it
doesn't mean that I don't feel that way
right you know what I mean it's still
hard even though you know like it
shouldn't be wrong crying in front of
someone but there's a certain perception
or there's maybe it's all you've ever
known maybe it was your dad a crier yeah
I remember the first time that my dad
cried in front of me cried he cried
after my great-grandfather his
grandfather called him and saying happy
birthday and he was telling me about it
then he grabbed my hand and I looked up
and he was crying and I'd never seen my
dad cry I didn't know that adult men
could cry I've never seen my dad cry how
do you not never it's jarring the first
time that you see it it's uh I mean we
never forget it
never I was I was 12 years old remember
it to this day we're sitting at the
kitchen table do you realize that this
is already the best podcast I've ever
had really you know why because I don't
know if it's that I caught you in a time
of just pure vulnerability but it is so
it's it's just it's powerful in a sense
that I remember just leaving a show when
I wasn't even the lead and I remember
partly it's like it's all over and I
know in a way you're like I want to go
back
being a father I want to go back to
Beemer and you're late but regardless
underneath all that is that is the end
of something
you've been a part of I don't know maybe
a fifth of your life something like that
well I mean I'm twenty Twenty twenty
five percent of it
twenty five so to end something like
that to then say okay let's go back to
the world back to life I don't want to
go back to I want I want to go on
vacation you want to go on Vicky where
do you want to I go to Africa you want
to do something at retrospect I mean I'm
going away we're taking our daughter to
Disney we're gonna spend Christmas in
London any time some someone would ask
something of me for the past month I'm
I'm like offended you know what I mean
so I leave me alone oh it's just been
people constantly [ __ ] telling me
what I have to do I don't have to do
[ __ ] no I need to be a husband and a
father that's in a decent friend that's
and a son that's all that I need to do
Horton Lee and I'm not a doctor yeah
I've been to many but you know what you
need to do you need to take care of your
[ __ ] self I know before you could
take care of your family and that's why
your wife is probably that's why she's
like gonna just see somebody because I'm
worried about you and I'm not a doctor
so of course that comes out of love of
course it comes out of and it's like
she's genuinely worried about horse and
I'm worried about you I'm looking at you
but I'm worried about you in a way that
I know a few months from now that you're
gonna you're gonna be great you're gonna
be recharged you're gonna be happy
you're gonna feel like God I feel like a
great dad right now I feel like I have
the energy to do things yeah you know
and that that's just the reality that's
not me trying to make you feel good
that's like it's gonna take some time
you're in mourning of a show that was
part of your life from a quarter of your
life you are also physically and
mentally spent there are moments in my
life where that's what happened that's
why I went to that clinic you know I
told you that yeah that's why I went man
I uh I've considered going to something
like that you know what
it's the best thing I could have done I
for me I think you've always like had a
good grasp of like who you are I think
you are more mature than I am I think
you had good role models I think you
were probably loved a little more than
or at least felt more loved than I was
with so what I'm saying is I don't think
I really grew up at all until I went to
this place and realized things that I
never when they said things like hey
you're relearning I stopped them with
tears of mouth and said no I'm [ __ ]
learning I'm learning for the first time
I'm a first grader in art class and I'm
sitting here with a woman who's patient
who's looking at me and so it was
life-changing for me it really was and I
have a lot of work to do and I'm just
like going when she'd go I went in July
for 22 days Jesus why you know they say
it takes 21 days to break a habit right
sure
so that was did they say that I didn't
know that when I went there okay I felt
like I was in fact I remembered you know
I said something to I've never really I
haven't talked I don't think as much
about this but I will with you because
you're being as vulnerable so I'll be
just as voting okay I remember I walked
in there and I sat down with one of the
therapists and I go I don't expect you
to be able to help me you have people in
here that are rock bottom with drugs and
alcohol and I'm not really in on any of
that stuff I mean I take some sleeping
pills and xanax and mm-hmm
but I'm just like I don't I'm a little
[ __ ] lost man I am a lost [ __ ]
soul and I'm tired of feeling sorry for
myself I don't reach out to anybody
really because they I can't even
articulate what's going on in my head I
can't even like put sentences together
to tell someone how I'm actually feeling
because it goes in so many different
directions one of my friends went there
and I go he was really low this person
went there and they were [ __ ] low I'm
not as low as that but I'm probably you
know I don't know I remember saying if
this person was at 2 I was probably I'm
like a 4 maybe yeah when I left that
place the woman
me down shoes remember coming in here
and saying you know all these things yes
because you were lower than your friend
and that I immediately started crying
yeah
because someone acknowledged how I've
been feeling they actually understood
that I was in such a [ __ ] up place and
I needed to make drastic changes and I
had been work and I were like I want to
live I want to enjoy life I want to and
it's very easy for people to judge it's
very easy for people to say come on dude
get a great life get a great house but
there was stuff that went out of my life
that I just never took care of I never
took care of myself
yeah so you gotta take care of yourself
you know I also think that probably over
the course of over the course of eight
years said to my wife today I'm like I
think over the course of eight years I I
missed almost a year's worth of sleep I
do not doubt that for a [ __ ] you know
minute shoot until five o'clock in the
morning and I'd be on a seven o'clock
flight how do you do that I don't know
because I remember thinking how is
Welling doing this on Smallville
how is he doing that because I would
work three days out of the five maybe
four but like I'd have a little time off
and sure I mean the hours were long I
shake my head but I couldn't do what he
did yeah I couldn't do what you did I
don't maybe it's you I kiss younger than
me I disagree with you if Smallville had
been about Lex Luthor and you had to
keep Tom's hours you would have done it
I would have did on it you would have
done but I've I would be where you are
now
yeah I would be struggling I would when
did you wrap November 15th
dude you it's not even a month I know
your body is going through such changes
cuz you when's the last time you had
more than like three months off in your
life two months off in your life 2009 10
years ago is the last time when you were
also 28 years old it's exactly right
yeah what's your body like when you're
young you don't even realize you could
just do whatever you could sleep till
you go to bed at 4:00 in the morning
wake up at 5:00 and yeah you somehow can
do it but when the older you get and
that's why at 47 now I couldn't I
couldn't I don't interest me they offer
me stuff I'm not gonna lie they offer me
I've been offered series one-hour series
and I don't know unless it's a ten
episodes or eight episodes a year and I
have ample time to learn my [ __ ] and I'm
not because I don't want to bury myself
in the ground yeah trying to do
something that I'm just not willing to
put myself through I mean I I took
another series immediately I know as the
lead as but it's eight episodes eight
episodes and it's something that you
really love yeah I mean you love
wrestling yeah what's it called
it's a healed arse heals when do you
start with March 15th or so March 15th
yeah so you have plenty of time yeah I
got a lot of training to do starting in
January but yeah I got a lot of time but
eight episodes eight episodes when I saw
that video last year of you wrestling
Chris Daniels
yeah Christopher Daniels have you seen
that Ryan all right no you know I think
when people thought Oh an actor is gonna
wrestle with one of these professionals
I'm a judge people before I [ __ ] know
him I'm not gonna lie to you I've done
that sure my like Troy [ __ ] you Troy you
hear me I love you he knows it but then
I see this video you have to see him
wrestle you're doing [ __ ] that I'm like
why are they letting him do this how was
he not dying
I didn't ask that's how they let me it
is beyond me and so tell me this when
you do this new if you guys haven't seen
it look up Stephen Amell wrestling but
will they look up W duh it's Stephen
Amell all in all in its it's to me it's
unbelievable I know you'll watch and
shut your pants but you're you're a
wrestler in this series yeah please
please don't let let them do your stunts
I'm not gonna have a stunt double
I can't I'm gonna be in a speedo how the
[ __ ] am I gonna have a stable I don't to
get to some video you gonna you're gonna
you're gonna be in a speedo you know
we're wrestling trunks we call them
trunks but it's ostensibly a speedo so
your body has to look really good you
don't look like The Undertaker you want
to look more like I did I I want to get
a thicker actually like I had like I
don't I don't wanna I don't want to be
like super ripped I want to look strong
you wanna look like a wrestler yeah like
a real [ __ ] yeah tough big [ __ ]
yeah a lot of work to do on my legs too
that's gonna do the biggest thing how
often will you wrestle um I think in
first episode my character wrestles like
three times do you are crazy [ __ ] you
jump off the ropes do you do a flip I'm
gonna have to do some creep are you
gonna flip yourself yeah I could do a
front flip on the trampoline so can i I
can't do a back one I can you can yeah
Ryan not a chance no no not even a
little bit you know I hate to ask this
to you but you know I'm not gonna I'm
not asking anything give you now because
I heard what you said don't stop asking
me but come March when this show comes
out or when you start filming come out
to August I'm gonna want you to come on
and promote that I actually don't know
when it airs oh come back come on dude I
think it'll come on I think it'll
probably come out in the fall but I
don't know I could be making that up
that's something that it's written for
you that was that was the funny thing is
uh they went out to UM they went out to
another actor who's whose name I'll
leave out of this and I don't know if
they didn't know I was available but
they're like you know we've we've got
this I've got this wrestling show called
heels at Stars and we've gone out to
actor X and the first three people that
they said that to they go to Steven and
I'll pass and they they rescinded their
offer to this guy and offered it to me
Wow how pissed was he don't know you
know what I wouldn't be that pissed if I
found out that my body couldn't handle
this kind of stuff right now I'd get a
stunt double for sure if they asked me
to walk across the street I might stunt
double better be there cuz you know it's
dangerous yeah you could easily get hit
by a car as easy as you could fly you
know whatever I'm happy for you so am I
so there are good things I think also
right I also I liked it I was a little
worried that I was you know like I was
like going home with the first girl that
smiled at me at the bar you know what I
mean but it's such a good project and
the scripts are really great and it's
funny and you have half a December
January and February before you even
really have it and I'll tell you what
I'm gonna tell you something you might
you have more power than you think
you said hey I just want January off to
recoup with my family another just one
month can you just push one month they
would do it yeah they asked me what I
wanted to start okay so say April take
an extra month I'm fine with March don't
tell me what to do do you think that
your your you have yet to mourn this
show like being done with it do you
think that's gonna hit you when you
least expect it or do you think your
like you're just it's been so that
you're pretty much done this is you're
good you've been wanting this to end
even though you love it you love the
fans
I do love I do love the fans I just
don't want any responsibility right now
other than a husband and father I really
are you gonna go see someone and you're
not gonna do that I might think I might
I wish you can go see this guy doctor
tesslar Rowan Connecticut this old
Jewish guy is it hot in here or am I
just sweating like I say you are
I am I don't know why hey look if you're
cool with me sweating I'll just sit here
and sweat no don't worry about it man
sweating honestly man I think I might be
sick you want to throw up yeah oh yeah I
might have to cut this short man I'm not
feeling well at all really yeah why
don't you leave you want but while first
you drink someone I'm gonna get you some
my tylenol no I think I just got to go
actually just kind of want to walk to
minds yeah I just need I just need fresh
air dude come on
thanks buddy inside of you is brought to
you by Warby Parker I'm wearing them now
Ryan you see these these are Warby
Parker's it's my specs yup and I went
out to lunch with a girl today and she's
like some people don't look good in
glasses but you do and I'm like Warby
Parker and so what she sounds like um
now why did I make her sound like that
she was actually way smarter than me so
I just don't
how to sound like a really smart girl I
don't know it was just it was just a
lady version of you maybe that's why
it's smart yeah first I'll say they're
awesome they really are they're
comfortable or just low light but the
fact is Ryan I went online I just click
glasses that I thought were cool I'd
like that those look good on me this
type doesn't so I just chose five pair
of glasses and what happens is they send
you these glasses and you try them on
for free you don't have to even buy them
ships for free includes a prepaid return
shipping label it's pretty phenomenal
and I was like you know a glass is that
but when you choose five one usually
fits with these actually a couple fit
but I chose these and now I want to get
another pair they're pretty dope you
gotta admit right they're really nice
yeah they are nice yeah and you go to
the places and you're like oh my god
this is like four hundred dollars plus
the lenses and
they're really expensive but Warby
Parker makes it affordable and that's
what I like about them head to Warby
Parker comm slash I owe you you take a
quick quiz I'm not good at quizzes this
was easy because you just pick what you
like you take a little quiz you order
your free home try on introducing Scout
by Warby Parker comfortable breathable
affordable daily contact lenses they got
those there too made from a super moist
material that resists drying for lasting
hydration and comfort order a trial pack
that includes six days worth of context
only five dollars then receive five
dollars off your next Warby Parker order
you guys are gonna love this place Warby
Parker get to it almost 1 billion people
worldwide lack access to glasses that's
15 percent of the global population
can't effectively learn to work which is
crazy because glasses were invented how
many years ago like a long time ago get
your glasses make sure you head to Warby
Parker calm /i oh you take that little
quiz free home try on and shipping
learn more at Warby Parker comm slash I
owe you Warby Parker comm slash I owe
you
inside of you is brought to you by tushy
you know I like this product Ryan
cuz it's for your but it's for my but
the don't fast forward you all need
things for your butt tushy I'm gonna be
honest with you it's praised your ass
with fresh water it's not toilet water
but I think that's what people think
they're like that but its water but it's
dirty
till she connects to the water supply
behind your toilet to spray your dirty
parts with clean fresh water it's the
same water you brush your teeth with her
but she didn't know that Ryan I did not
know that serious thing I could use a
bidet to brush my teeth you might know I
would do that it's a new thing like
because here bidet used to she do use
wet wipes or any other thing you what do
you do with your butt toilet paper
standard well wet wipes are worse than
toilet paper they're terrible for the
environment because I know a lot of
people do that and I was doing that and
it they cause anal fissures you don't
want your anus fishery nope
79 bucks 79 bucks to have your ass
cleanly sprayed every day with fresh
water and not wasting all that paper
wasting all that I mean ass juice all
over it like you can I have to wash you
you might not even have to wash your
hands after this tushie thing you should
probably still wash your hands well I
I'm not touching my butthole you should
still do it it's just a sleek bidet
attachment it clips under your existing
toilet sprays your buck completely clean
with fresh water it's called Toshi okay
guys it's the best thing you can do for
your butt go - hello - she calm /aou and
get 10% off your order
that's hello Toshi dot-com /aou and get
10% off your order
hello Toshi comm / IOU hey guys it's
Michael Rosenbaum this next part this is
the second half of the interview of
Stephen Amell what you just heard was a
guy who was exhausted and you know there
were as much as he plays a superhero on
TV you know were human beings and I
commend him for coming back and talking
to me but he had to go he had to cut
this interview short as you hear and it
was it was a little bit it was a little
crazy as you're gonna hear so Lissa's uh
Stephen comes in two weeks later and
this is how he finished the interview I
thought that for the new part I miss
make sure my phone is off the
you part on heels on heels that I would
go with Savage look and I would go with
a mustache so I cut my hair really short
started to grow the mustache there's no
good time to start growing a mustache
like those if you can make it through
the first couple of days you're in good
shape
you grow a fast though well yeah but I
when did I
they got shaved right when I got to over
the Christmas break right when I got
anyone know I was in Florida Florida I
shaved in Dallas I think I shaved in
Florida and then I was in London and I
let it grow for a little bit and then I
went to one of those grooming shops
which I love so much I would have
grooming shops like you note you know
the Ted Baker products I do yeah there's
Ted Baker grooming stores you go in
there and it's like the groom you it's
like 40 or 50 pounds or something like
that
and you're in there for an hour they cut
your hair they shave you they they
massage your arms they well they wax
your back yeah well what [ __ ] bears I
think I I think I think basically its
neck down your neck down you're on your
own
uh I think so like a group that's I mean
it sounds kind of like sounds okay but I
also wanted like a professional to set
the parameters of the mustache because I
didn't want a too too small
that's one thing but too big that's sort
of like caricature II I don't know I
think that this character - I like this
and by the way I look at you and I
guaranteed say the word brother
differently with this - like without the
mustache you might be brother but this
might be brother brother no I like it
you know you're a wrestler right and
when does it take place in the 80s or
now not present days it's just rising to
the present day it's just small town
it's called Duffy Georgia well you're
also a really lucky you're a really
good-looking guy so with a mustache
you're still good-looking but it gives
you like an off like kind of weird he's
attractive but you know I could escape
for a minute with the Mel's monster
I also it's really great being around my
wife every time someone complements me
on it cuz she doesn't like it I don't
know and you just look at her and go huh
see there you go he liked it no but I
had my hair really short I mean it's
been growing for like two weeks but I
don't know new year
I actually don't I don't know why I said
that I don't believe in any of that [ __ ]
what's the new year
the whole new year whatever it just so
happens that the new year is coincided
with a sort of a new chapter in my life
but new year so we'll come over hang out
let's take a break here like you don't
believe in the whole resolutions yeah
you don't believe all right dude I spent
my friend Rob and I granted we smoked a
little bit of a joint I'm not
recommending that you don't need to but
a few days before the new year and we
set we went back to my house and we just
like rode out two dudes rode out all the
things we want to do all the things we
want to accomplish so they're there in
riding and then I then I typed them up
the next day and they're in front of me
so I could look at them and say this is
what you want to accomplish this is what
you wrote down these were your wants and
your things and your desires why don't
you stick to these things instead of
just [ __ ] around and not having any
real I don't structure whatever but why
January 1st no what do you mean why
before before January why not or January
why not October 6th because it just
doesn't seems like big it's like you're
doing it for the rest it like this is
alright you've had enough [ __ ] in your
life in your life last year these are
all the things I did these are all the
things that were bad that happened this
is all the [ __ ] but you know what in
about few more days I can enjoy and then
this is when you get busy this is when
you start doing all these things and and
people usually leave them after a few
weeks right everybody all that lasted a
month I don't know I think I'm pretty
strong lately I think I could I could
stick to stuff I mean when I used to
work in a when I used to work at a gym
to teaching spinning you taught spinning
what year oh gosh tooth out
it in 2002 was it fun yeah I mean it was
how I kind of got into acting and so far
as I was able to teach and make enough
money that I could go and I could
audition spinning coach make they make
good money
no you make okay
I mean like 50 bucks of class and how
many class was a day sometimes like five
so you were ripped you know when you
first start teaching you get really
skinny and then you get in this weird
pseudo in shape because you're active
but not really doing anything to better
yourself because there's no physical way
that you can exert yourself over three
classes four classes five classes when
your job is also to motivate people and
to go around and to in effect be a
teacher or an instructor there's no way
that you can put the same amount of
effort into those classes so you get
into this sort of weird zone whereas if
you're participating in the class and
maybe you do one or two but you do a
spin class and you know you basically
get five six workouts over the course of
a week but you really commit yourself to
them you're getting way better shape
doing that than teaching dude I am the
reason I'm laughing is you're telling a
story you're thinking it's not really
funny what I'm saying but what I'm
laughing it as imagine you as a spin
instructor with that mustache we're
going up brother brother
all right look there's an elephant in
the room and you know I should have
started with this but I didn't feel the
need to but last time you came in yeah
it was it would look completely
different you your whole disposition
yeah it was because of this it was
because of the setup of your room I knew
you couldn't get the door open but what
happened was was so important cuz I
remember yeah so if you've looked by the
way if they're listening you obviously
they just heard what happened and we
jump into this and it's interesting
because I didn't know exact right Ryan
yeah what yeah you know really well he
says you were white you know he's just
like I just hope he's okay I don't know
and but I know panic attacks
I know overwhelmingness and I could tell
you were sweating I tell you and that
really I don't know you just weren't
well for starters I shouldn't have I
should do it I should have cancelled
yeah for sure yeah yeah I don't know why
in fact I said that they why would you
like you
yeah so just love the [ __ ] part I do
well I mean I left here I tried to drive
I tried
no I I walked home you tried to you
pulled up beside me and tried to drive
me I drove down the street I was
freezing on the walk but not because I
was I was just freezing because I was
just bought in the cold wet and then the
cold and I got I got home I got onto the
couch put a blanket over me and again
was freezing but just sweating bullets
and you know told my wife I just said
I'm having a I had a really bad panic
attack and I texted her after I said I
just gotta check up on him
oh really I did she knew tired you don't
don't please don't say anything and
that's what I was worried about you and
that's why I was like [ __ ] you know Jess
was like whoa
or who said it maybe it was just like
well it's rush hour all these cars I
think he's having a panic attack you
should and I was racing getting my truck
you like I'm fine yeah I just wanted to
listen to him I wanted to listen to a
podcast and walk by myself actually not
yours right that's all right it's okay
that's okay you left mine to listen to
another what were you thinking when you
were I mean when you were walking down
the you know what happened earlier in
the day I was pretty positive that there
was nothing physically wrong with me but
as we discussed the leaving of the show
combined with just not really breaking
away from it
in my life just in terms of getting back
into Los Angeles and it was like I
needed this clean this clean break I
needed to go on a trip I needed to drop
my phone I needed to you just had him
disconnect I just hadn't disconnected
and ironically I had said with code
eight coming out that you know ideally
I'm gonna be in Los Angeles I'm you know
I'm gonna take the break from
mid-november until Thanksgiving and then
you guys have me for three weeks or two
weeks or whatever we need for
for prep and I shouldn't have done that
now that being said that's when they
decided to put out the movie and I
needed to promote the movie but and I'm
not laying this all defeat of Co date
because I love the people that were
involved and they were very fair just
done
they were very fair and equitable with
my time but I was just done it could
have been anything didn't matter what it
could have been if it was Turtles back
in the day could have been it could have
been an award show campaign because I
was playing Pitt's part and Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood doesn't wouldn't it
doesn't matter
your daughter's done isn't that
something when the body I've been there
when you're because a lot of times like
you know just go work out I'll feel
better I'll just know do this I'll be
fine and then there comes a time where
your body just goes no you're not doing
any of that well that was the other part
that was the other problem too is that
I'd gotten into such a rut with physical
fitness or lack thereof
that there was no there was no physical
release there was no release of there
was no there was no release of
endorphins I I even found myself like
with with very little not to get too
personal but with very little sexual
appetite just because I was doing
nothing except just digging myself into
a rut with my body and there was some
form of a talking about it with you and
just talking about it in general and be
going to the doctor earlier that day and
realizing that in fact nothing was
[ __ ] wrong with me and that's when
you have that moment of realization
where you go oh oh my god this is in my
head like what just sometimes scarier it
is scarier because you're like I'd
rather them I'd rather than tell me no
no no no no you need to get your spleen
removed
yeah or you've got [ __ ] up or
something but no there was there was
nothing that's how it happened I think
it [ __ ] me up and I don't know how to
deal with it I was on set and I had a
panic attack and I said to Troy my
sister said hey man get the doctor here
I don't feel well I feel like I was
having a heart attack whatever he gets
on there checks my vitals like he goes
well you had a physical this is Michael
have you ever had a panic attack worst
thing he could have [ __ ] said to me
yeah and I go no what and I was
embarrassed I never told anybody I had
panic attack
so I had like four or five on that set
after that never told anybody just said
I had diarrhea I had to jump run off set
people just laugh I was gonna make him
laugh that's me hey I'm funny that
diarrhea I know like where's Rosenbaum
and I'm literally in the looking in the
mirror at myself going you're fine
you're fine and xanax doesn't work after
that you know you take a chance after
you having a panic attack it might it
takes it just do it
well even talking with doctors the thing
that they'll tell you is that one of the
best things that you can do is just to
self-soothe which is easy unless you
have a kid a what do you wanna be myself
soon well self-soothe like leave me
alone just just leave me alone and let
me catch my breath
and that is easy for me but really
difficult for my wife because she wants
to help right and I want to tell her you
can help by waiting for me to ask you
for help if in fact I need it otherwise
I'm just trying to catch a rhythm of
breath and get everything under control
and the minute that a door opens or
something drops on the floor or you sit
down on the bed and put your hand on my
shoulder it's like I'm back at square
one but the biggest thing the biggest
thing for me was just all of a sudden it
was like okay I think we did it on a
Thursday or maybe on a Friday what the
podcast I'm trying to I'm trying to
remember what Jimmy whoa
but I went home I laid on the couch had
an IV service come to the house and they
just pumps me full of fluid that help
and vitamins and there was something
that they gave me directly in the IV
that will make you drowsy if you take it
anyway but putting it in an IV it the
name is escaping me right now it's one
of those basically it's one of those
like cold medicine throw that G no not M
F F F everyone no no it's like it's uh
know that you know gosh whatever you can
get better but the point is is that they
popped it into the first bag or I think
it was actually possibly because I was
all shaky they also gave me something
for that
but they popped it right in there during
the first bag and I got this I got the
second bag and the IV taken out of my
arm while I was fast asleep you were out
I was out really I was totally out
Brinson yeah you can buy it at a CVS
just so happens when they pump it right
into your veins knocks you right out but
I listened to the podcast because I
asked you to send me that yeah the wrong
is that that's true what I was thinking
was one I got you know Stephens many
people I'm sure would have gone no no
never air that it's embarrassing I don't
want to do that and then I thought well
you know this is exactly what my
audience needs listen to the world needs
to listen to he plays a superhero he's
been on this for eight years he's never
rested he has a family he's doing so
much things I don't know how he's
juggling at all he hit a wall he's
[ __ ] tired and guess what superhero
got tired
yeah he's that's a real person he had
anxiety and I was hoping you'd say one
or two things I gave you a go look we
could can it we could I could finish it
and just say hey you had a panic attack
he's doing fine now blah blah blah you
go now I want to come in yep I mean if
you're hearing this I'm sure that you'll
do some sort of intro to it probably I'm
gonna do an intro but well you know in
100 really no I I mean I've done
wonderful if they're listening now okay
well of course right but if you if you
want to go back and listen to it from
the time that I come on and I start
talking I don't take back anything that
I said I could hear my voice that maybe
I was a little low on on patience and
maybe I was a little bit more I wouldn't
say defamatory but direct right maybe
slightly PI mouths more than I would
normally be but the general elements of
what I said I don't take any issue with
but I could hear myself over the last
three four minutes of the of the raw
file I could hear my breathing yeah
start to become a little bit labored
yeah you could just sense that like
something was I was and I was starting
to sweating you go hey he's sweating is
it hot in here that if you rewind you
could hear more more the stuff and it
wasn't hot maybe like I tried out the
[ __ ] door but I just had it sustained
the guy's stained the [ __ ] door out
there so I couldn't get it open
I think I was getting anxiety like you
know what I'm gonna [ __ ] go I think
it was all these things this culmination
of all these things that were happening
well do you look you powered through as
much as you could and the fact that
you're here I think that what what this
says is like this is how many weeks
later couple weeks later do communities
later but but but but it's the b-side of
a very important break a very important
break and the month of January for me is
just very very different than what I
felt like mid-november through basically
a couple of days after I came on with
you going away that stretch of time that
was really weird
I took real stock in the fact that I was
taking a break and that I really needed
to and that I was gonna enjoy my holiday
but I've been looking forward to January
more than I was even the break really
sure yeah just starting something new
being refreshed yeah I'm taking my kid
to camp this week and I'm training for
heels and did you ever worry did you
ever think first of all aren't you lucky
that maybe this didn't happen on set
like it happened after it was all done
do you think if that would have happened
on set like you were like what would you
have done if you started getting these
panic attacks and you couldn't rest
cause you're working because you told me
something I think in the beginning which
I would have to go he said something
like I don't think I've ever I really
slept in the last eight years yeah I
said I said I said that basically over
the past eight years I've missed a good
like a good hours sleep excuse me a good
years a good year out of the eight I've
probably missed a year because like I
said it's it's it's it's five o'clock on
set at seven o'clock on a plane you go
you go you go you go you go and then you
know I had incidents like this my
typical Christmas break was I get off
have a bunch of drinks with friends
something like that something like that
for like two three days if I'm not going
straight away and then I have this lull
in the Christmas break where I sleep and
I relax and then I get excited to go
back to work but invariably you know
back in the day there was this crash at
the end of this
but then starting after season 3 of 8
there was no break in between 3 and 4 I
went straight to turtles and I shot at
the entirety of the break and in between
4 and 5 I promoted Turtles and then in
between 5 and 6 I went away for a little
bit but then we shot all of code 8 and
in between 6 & 7 I went away like on
this beautiful trip but then come came
back and shot code 8 and went right back
to work and there's just no break just
no break you're not taking care of
yourself I mean take it alright either
I'm just not taking a break and a break
I think stopping working out was a real
big contributing factor because there's
got to be this if there's gonna be a
yang there's got to be a yang you can't
just be the yang you know what I mean
like I used to take real solace in
getting on a treadmill or getting out on
the road and running hard for 40 minutes
50 minutes 60 minutes 90 minutes and you
weren't doing that for how long before
you had this panic attack I had been
doing it for the better part of a year
when I had that wrestling match I
fractured my hip and all of a sudden I
was back being very physical on the show
but I wasn't really doing anything
outside of the gym and then you know and
then that becomes and then you know
October becomes November and November it
becomes December and then all of a
sudden I don't really need to be
shirtless on the show so frog code so
[ __ ] it and then you know I'm going what
what did I even do you know we had this
big long round-the-world trip planned
you know I was exercising a little bit
maybe I think just just very
sporadically but being active and going
out and hiking and stuff like that and
then and then and then my wife had a had
a a Vespa accident when we were in my
Orca and we had to cut the trip short
and being all of a sudden it just that
wasn't that wasn't a root cause for not
exercising but you know there was a lot
of issues going back for season eight
for me
just because I thought that seven was
the logical conclusion you were done
let's just face it I was done and you're
kind of ready to move on and then you
couldn't move on I was ready to move on
and then you I got the proverbial offer
that I that I couldn't refuse like show
no no for season eight of arrow oh right
because they they say alright well
alright you want to be done at season
seven okay well you're gonna have to
shoot 22 episodes with us that was more
than you'd ever shot no we know we shot
twenty-three for the first six seasons
but they're like you cannot you know we
didn't actually know we're gonna do 22
for season seven but they're like well
you know you're gonna have to do 22 with
us which is July through April so are
you really telling us that you want to
do 22 at price X and and finish in April
and not do 32 at this price and be done
in October that doesn't make any sense
right because they're if you're
negotiating they change your episodic
fee and I looked at it and they
literally put me in a position they put
me in a position nobody put me in any
position it would have been fiscally
irresponsible for me to say no right
just just fiscally irresponsible so and
I loved the [ __ ] out of season eight I
had a blast but I was there for the
money right more so than I had ever
loved and money love and money
but certainly money you put your kids to
get your kid through school I don't
regret the choice and I think that I
feel like everyone makes the same choice
I worked out with with Welling today and
he was telling me that well he just told
me he doesn't want to go see ambrosia
with me on Saturday really you know
Ambrose you know that's how much I feel
I feel for you baby
70s man but you can understand why but I
love that man anyway I'm good shape well
I was getting good she got in good shape
for the wedding yeah and I you know I
keep telling my know wow you look really
good he does you know it's a big super
superhero style yeah he is a big guy but
he was telling me that he felt a certain
way after season seven and that there
was a lot of him that was ready to be
done that's because I love
[ __ ] there you go I'll get him he did
but then he said you know once I got
over that hurdle and and I did season 8
he goes season 8 season 9 season 10 I
had a blast and I had a blast during
season eight but there was a part of me
and it certainly wasn't all money
because I didn't negotiate with Warner
Brothers at all for season eight they
just kept coming back with different
offers not necessarily monetary offers
uh mostly monetary but also it was Greg
Berlanti that sort of like came with the
lifestyle offer of what if such a thing
as a half season existed for you which
wasn't to say that the show was gonna do
a half season but what if you just did a
half season and it was like well yeah
cuz I wanted to go on a trip with my
family but then the moment that I
stepped back on set I just there was
just a part of me that was like you need
to stay a little just a little too long
just a little do you think
does it ever concern you that you'll
you'll have another panic attack or do
you feel like you know what now I know
what to do I've learned my lesson I
learned how to disconnect and go ahead
take a break I learned how to say no in
a certain way I learned how to you know
maybe it's working out more maybe it's a
combination of a lot of things but do
you think does that fear ever cross your
mind like hey I didn't like this feeling
or you just feel like hey my mind knows
that this there was nothing physically
wrong with me and that's important by
the way yeah because I had a doctor tell
me this actually is it therapist
therapist goes when you're having a
panic attack here's I don't you do ask
yourself is there anything wrong with me
there's anything wrong with my heart now
had my heart checked I have a great
heart yeah is there anything wrong with
your liver who ever without know you
just got tested for everything right so
you know what this says this is in your
mind so what do you think you need well
you probably should there's a lot of
things there's a lot of things to
prevent anxiety right so don't be
drinking a lot of caffeine especially
you know late in the day you know make
sure you get sleep working out diet
there's all these things that don't use
alcohol drugs anything that you do that
alters your mind I don't worry about it
as much because retrospectively
this was not a situation where I came
over and because I didn't like the
furniture set up in your room and it's
actually true that I was like I couldn't
get right now I'm very comfortable and
not just because I'm feeling a room
around but you changed the room around
and I felt like I was constantly worried
about leaning forward to get to the mic
but then I was tired and I felt like I
was sitting weird my point being is that
this panic attack
did not hit me when I was sitting in
this room this panic attack was in the
[ __ ] mail right it was it was in
evidence when I was really dragging
myself around the day before and it was
in evidence when I tried to cancel going
to the doctor that day and couldn't pick
myself up off the ground and it was in
evidence when you know everything in my
mind told me not to come over and do the
podcast but my brain wasn't functioning
properly and I was still on the mindset
of I can't let people down I always
that's my whole thing I always think I'm
gonna let people down so I always got
yeah doing stuff did you by the way I
want to talk about that for a second but
did you go did you do your wife asked
did you go see someone
I haven't we haven't spoken with anyone
either usually we haven't spoken we're
in a fight we're divorced I haven't
spoken with anyone professionally that's
something that we utilized when we were
up in Vancouver and we've actually
spoken with a couple of friends of ours
who had some really great
recommendations for both when we're down
here and when I'm off in Atlanta
shooting but just we found it incredibly
helpful sometimes we would sit in there
she would talk for 80 minutes and I
would just sit there and listen or I
would talk for 80 minutes and she would
just sit there and listen and sometimes
we talk about our relationship and
sometimes we talk about other people all
right but we're gonna get back into that
but you think that helps it does help
although I don't know that it relates to
the panic attacks I think that it's more
in pursuit of a better relationship for
us I would like to I
that I would be well-served to have
someone that I can do a a mental check
in since I can't come on your podcaster
for four weeks but you could actually I
told I told Welling today I'm like I'm
going over to Rosenbaum's house today he
goes oh yeah I go yeah I had a I did his
podcast before the break and I had a
[ __ ] panic attack right in the middle
of it he goes no he didn't yeah I did he
goes there are worse places to have
right yeah well you know what the
reality is it's I was just like hey I
was worried about you I was like I know
you're gonna get through this you know
you're gonna power through it I don't
want to hear I didn't want to hear that
at the time but I appreciate it yeah
yeah yeah I don't think I said did I say
that what you said like but this is
before it happened
you're you know but but I was clearly
you know I thought it was pretty panic
attack or no I thought I was pretty
forthcoming that I was having a
different I loved it I was so shocked I
was so shocked really that you said you
know I'm gonna go you could have just
left it looked at yeah I'm gonna go I'm
not feeling well let you get no I'm I'm
having a panic attack
again I I think that it's just like
seeing you go through this and now that
we see what you're doing to prevent it
and and knowing that you know people
move ahead and also the place that you
had it in that's a key like I always
hear like you know from therapists
they'll say if you have a panic attack
and you run right it's important for you
to face the place where you had it yeah
and you came back and you might be like
you know I had a panic attack out of
there I don't want to go back I don't
know I've had that situation where my oh
my god I had it here I don't you know if
you have it on set and you run off then
you're like [ __ ] and every time you go
on set you don't get anxiety mm-hmm well
supposedly I mean I dealt with one
towards the latter part of season seven
of arrow I can't I can't remember what
triggered it the time you think of it I
bet maybe fatigue sure I got in touch
with their first assistant director and
I was like I'm I'm not doing well
physically right now I'm I'm having a
I'm having an issue with anxiety and I'm
gonna come into work
I'm not great and he wasn't actually the
first assistant director on set that day
but the other first assistant director
it was her her first or second episode
and I didn't [ __ ] know I didn't know
her right
I liked her but I didn't know her right
so I had him just let all the all the
people you know feel comfortable good
you didn't know her I didn't know her
right married and I got my work done
that day I asked to do my pieces of a
fight that ended the day early and I
spent every possible moment that I could
in my trailer actually listening to the
calm a p-- on the on the iPhone I love
that app yeah I've been using that does
help yeah just that I've just been
listening to the daily comm which is
just 10 minutes I've been tracking my
sleep which is which is good just making
sure that all that doesn't mean that can
give you a little anxiety this sure I
can see I'm like wait a minute my heart
rate was this right at five at five
hours I mean I guess you kind of know if
you're sleeping well or not I know you
wake up and you feel rested or you yeah
or you know when you go to bed I mean I
I probably won't do that for much longer
but it's just nice to just get a track
on things but when it comes to facing
something the people on the arrow set
I'm sure that knew that something was
amiss I was fine with my work that day
you're probably your disposition was my
disposition was off at when if people
asked me how I was I said I'm not
particularly great but I'm okay but then
at the end of the day I I I thanked the
crew for their and and the cast for
their thoughtfulness for their
understanding for their patience I let
them know that I was having some issues
with anxiety and then I said but I'll
see you tomorrow
and I'm sure that I'll be better and
everyone you know I think people like
sort of tepidly applauded which was not
what I was looking for but well you're
brave but I faced I face that fear as
opposed to thinking to myself that
entire night those people are gonna be
wondering what the hell is wrong with me
because I'm just a I'm just a moody
actor up until I tell them that I'm
actually going through something
like oh my god that's why he was yeah
but at the same time their crew members
that are probably like yeah yeah you
know who get panic attacks the
celebrities that actors yeah what's the
matter buddy
not enough gold-plated threads on your
goddamn sheets brother brother let me
tell you something though I know it
sounds funny good on ya that's brave I
didn't do that I had anxiety attacks on
in pastor and instead of going to the
crew and saying hey ladies and gentlemen
I'm having a panic attack I me who's so
open maybe more so since I've been doing
this podcast because I didn't have a
podcast when I was doing that I couldn't
do that I pretended everything was okay
I pretend that I had diarrhea I pretend
that I had listen man I lie and until
one person except my assistant to do
usually uh-uh what do you want me to do
nothing I don't know anybody didn't know
the thing then all said I'm not they
can't work with me you know I'm gonna
get but that's not how it is it's like
you hit a wall well this cement look
this is the great thing this podcast
doesn't have to be long because we did
the first half-hour I got some time but
I mean look I'm excited for you and I
didn't think you know the turnaround is
like wow - two weeks and look I don't
think you're done doing things for
yourself that's just connect to you know
to keep that in check it's not like oh
that happened oh now I'm good and I'll
forget about what happened I think
that's in the back back back your mind
going hey I got to take care of myself
yeah and I think I give a whole lot of
credit to to my wife who very bravely
said look look buddy I need you to get
better right like for a variety of
reasons okay one of which is your to
yourself secondly you owe it to our kid
and third you [ __ ] owe it to me if
you think that you're at your best right
now then your [ __ ] best isn't good
enough that's a tough thing to say yeah
it's a really tough thing to say it's
even tougher when the person doesn't
want to hear it so I give her a lot of
credit because she said that she said
that stuff to me and you know I think
one of the biggest things is is
you want to fix it immediately I know
you want to snap your fingers and you
want it all to be better and that's not
the way that it works you got a you know
I'm back in the gym right now and I'm
just eating [ __ ] every day
humble pie like I'm going in there and
I'm benching less than I benched when I
was in twelfth [ __ ] grade going for
football because guess what when you
take a year off and you're in your late
30s [ __ ] goes away yeah I did you know
that's why old guys hike their pants up
above their button
yeah le button and look I have a lot of
faith that I'm gonna snap back but I was
in there today working out with a
retired NFL player who's like six five
wasn't he I know but he's uh you would
know if you like football you would you
would know of him I mean he was Pro
Bowler
I think his career got cut short by
injuries a little bit but like he was
like a player when at wet at the height
of his power she just like if you just
said his last name he's like oh yeah
yeah baby a big bit but he's you know
I'd have spar with him today not easier
no exhausted I am exhausted
I've been go to bed at like 7:30 at
night and get eating with arm 6:15 6:30
wait a minute that's 12 hours no clothes
well I would well I'm not a
mathematician but I can't sleep more
than like [ __ ] 6 or 7 hours I just
can't my mind's just too active I have
to right now I have to although I'm not
not I'm not straight through sleeping
and one of the things that I'm actually
working on is is going to sleep with
with with no sound because I've been
listening ear pods I've been listening
to to two podcasts that sort of help
fall asleep and then if I wake up I'll
just put something else on and yeah yeah
I'm trying to I got to work on that I
remember you said something by the way
when you were having that when we cry
you guys you know what I've already
cried twice today as last time yeah I
remember I was like wow that's when I
knew was right away so that's I cried
twice today I'm like whoa Steven Christ
twice yeah doesn't cry I don't think I
don't think Steven cries but
think that's probably also the way to
the world you feel like [ __ ] you're
tired you don't know why you're
disconnected you haven't disconnected
and then at the same time you feel like
you're like your wife dad I think you
know letting the world down and I was
sent say you know everybody needs help I
want to help people and want to be there
for them and all of a sudden who's there
for me yeah you got to take care of
yourself first like you said you got
stuff yeah I think that's true I think
you just got to Ryan you take care of
yourself buddy
yeah sure this is a man of many words
isn't it Steve yeah all right look man I
want to ask you some of these questions
I do this thing on patreon and it's just
like it's just ten quick questions you
wrap it fire though hit me with it
hit me with your best shot all right
this is easy this is Jerry W says
curious what your favorite role has been
and why Oliver Queen because it changed
my life simple see you are good at this
Jill E
how was it working on new girl really
good one of the most exciting days of my
entire career is I worked on private
practice and new girl at the same day
started on new girl went to private
practice went back to new girl I was
just holding on at that point just
trying to blend in but ironically one of
my first days on set I have to I have to
bust into a party asking everyone if I
have just pissed my pants so I had to be
pretty outsized and you know I'm in
there with max Greenfeld and and Zoe and
Hannah and you know Jake all these
ideologies like Ryan Quentin he's on
True Blood yeah he was the bigger he was
the bigger guest star in that it doesn't
matter kwa and TE n however you
pronounce that he's Australian guy
really good actor and I was just trying
to hang on but that experience was
really cool Trisha how was it working
with Tom and Michael on that's me a
knocking point it's been good I've
enjoyed it so far although I haven't
been around as much Wehling thanked me
today said you guys were gonna do some
social media stuff for it I have like
how you switched around yeah I'm the
pure he's the evilest it's right much
better yeah it was good one of your
biggest sellers last you know that it
was yeah thanks for inviting us to that
you welcome
Trisha B what was it like taking a role
so shortly after the final episode of
arrow don't know yet
yeah you don't get back to me in like
mid-march Trevor asks if you could
choose any duo's costume for Halloween
with Rosenbaum what would you choose
well my wife and I have already gone as
Franks and beans
which is my favorite as we were taking a
photo this girl comes up to us and it's
like are you guys dressed as Franks and
beans like yeah absolutely and she goes
you've got to come and meet my dad and
his brother oh my god they took us right
to the Farrelly Brothers and one of the
reasons that I'm one of the reasons that
I'm wearing the Franks and beans costume
or Frank and beans is because I'm such a
fan of The Fairly yeah like I'm a huge
fan of the Farrelly's yeah and yeah so
we had a nice chat with them but what I
don't know what would we do uh Dimpy
Laurel Hardy
Oh God you know what would be great is
if we should go as Jaime and Cersei
Lannister hold hands on the red carpet
can I be Jaime no hey let's go as let's
go as Billy Bob Thornton and Angelina
Jolie back when they were a couple I'm
in thanks Trevor s for that a lot of
options Nico P what scene do you
remember that took the longest to film
because people kept laughing Oh probably
just the scene in the bunker you know
just somewhere you get to the end of the
day nothing in particular comes to mind
but just probably fatigued you get to
the end of the day and it's you know I I
didn't used to have a trick for it and
then I would just think to myself I am
actively taking away time that I spent
with my family because I can't get my
[ __ ] together and then I would probably
go usually stop laughing but a good
laugh is nice and a good laugh is really
nice Nicole V in playing Oliver Queen
for eight seasons what did you learn
about him that surprised you most and
how did it affect how you portrayed him
if I learned something about Oliver
Queen
per se as as he's a character that that
obviously has some comic book and
obviously has some comic book origins
but you know was largely the creation
the creative team in my creation on
arrow just cuz it was a very different
version of the character I think I
learned a lot about how a character any
character can grow and change over the
course of time I like it too more Robert
be in your career what do you see is
your biggest waste of money
biggest waste of and that could be taken
anywhere maybe in your career what do
you see as your biggest waste of money I
mean is that like it doesn't cost to be
an actor in the game I mean or is he
talking about
you know you bought something at age 18
in my career I don't I don't know what
my career like I bought a van I still
have the van I don't give a [ __ ] it was
the best purchase ever all right that's
what he's talking about
I think the stupidest purchase I've ever
made was when I had a chevy cavalier z24
in like 1999 and i thought it needed a
cooler stereo [ __ ] who needs a subwoofer
and a Chevy Cavalier mmm that's because
you can go down a street just banging
they're too short let's remember how it
all began
Dionne K our crossovers fun for you to
shoot be honest no they're not they're
brutal aren't they no they're not brutal
you just can't they come out great
the fans love them I always think of
what we leave on the table because we
try and shoot something really
extraordinary overwhelming and with this
amazing scope within the confines of our
typical schedule it's never made any
sense to me it's just so frustrating so
hard and exhausting to accomplish in the
first episode of the crossover that has
already aired my character dies now he
comes back as this different DC
character which you know plays in part 4
of the crossover or part 4 and 5 of the
crossover but my characters die in
episode 1 and he's dying on a gurney in
the in the arrow bunker you know we're
left part of me is that where you left
you said in the book well yeah you love
me laughter this is not so much of a
laugh okay
but some of my lines my lines were to
cap Mac the merit Caity Lotz into grant
and they were trying to rap Katie and
grant because they had hit their 13 hour
marker whatever it was they were trying
to rap Katie and grant before I shot the
coverage of the scene where I died I
blame no one for this but this is a
scene with me from arrow that's taking
place on Supergirl
with a Supergirl crew with demands on
both grant and caity lotz who are on
flash and legends who are on a different
schedule than the crossover because
they're shooting different [ __ ] and
they're trying to pull them so that they
don't flash and legends mess up their
day the next day meanwhile the [ __ ]
Green Arrow was laying on a gurney
trying to deliver his lines to something
other than a [ __ ] tennis ball so you
know there are lots of scenes where you
know I'm acting and there just aren't
other actors there and that's just not
an acceptable way of creating the best
product from my perspective and I think
that it is a little bit disrespectful to
the actors and their process speaking
personally other actors might not give a
[ __ ] right for that moment and that
scene you pour that moment and for that
scene I mean I'm trying to think of what
the more important scenes are right and
it's not just because it involves my
character or my character's death but I
mean how hard is it to not prioritize
that you know what first of all Dion K I
appreciate your question yeah they still
kept they come out great they come out
great I'm glad that we do right they're
not the most fun to shoot Jo so thank
you for starting another panic attack
for Steven so thank you I got you a
little present
I saw that I told you this is the this
is a massage she's my girl Anastasia
she's amazing okay and I got one for you
and I want you to use her because she'll
come back she lives around the corner
and she's brilliant okay
she's not weird or anything she's uh
you'll love her you'll probably start
using her I like that it's on me don't
know [ __ ] nothing used it's all taken
care of
okay and I just think that you you need
that I think massage and your life is
gonna add massage I do good look it's
very important I think it's very
important whenever my wife and I go to a
nice hotel or like the force we love
that we love any Four Seasons anywhere
just because you know what you're
getting yeah you know like Four Seasons
some you just know what you're getting
and that like the quality of service is
just great but that we always yeah
massages and couples massages whenever
possible it's named combs at fart if she
was there worried about farting now I
worry about snoring oh that happens
where you wake up you pie and they're
used to it they're used to it but I
don't think that my wife falls asleep
during the massage so she would hear it
I always fall asleep during the massage
which is odd because she's getting the
Swedish or the floral or she getting
stones put on her or something like that
and I've got I've got a I've got a woman
with her elbow deep in my back and just
driving [ __ ] out of it and you're asleep
with that I fall asleep to that right
you I'm weird I kissed ik dude lastly
heels you're gonna be shooting that soon
you're getting prepared for it you know
I don't really want to act unless it's
something I want to do on producer I'm
working on or I really just love it I'm
like all there's an element of fun but
that when you said that I kept thinking
of the movie the rests on a man like
that that's what maybe was just a
brilliant movie and I don't know what
this is gonna be and I'm hopeful I'm
hoping it's gritty and a little dark and
a little you know not as it's all those
things there's a gritty element to it
just because there's a there's a grungy
element to the wrestling world well not
just that but to the independent
wrestling world I mean we're not we're
not if our promotion comes through town
we're not going to the [ __ ] [ __ ]
Staples Center not going to the forum
all right we're going to a to a-- to a
shitty so that element of it you know
the sort of the smoke-filled arenas like
back in the day
but at its heart it's it's about a you
know it's about a family and it's about
the the the characters that
populate the independent wrestling scene
and when I see characters I mean like
these people are characters you know
what I mean you have to be a little and
to all my to all my friends that are in
the business I you know I don't take
this back you got to be a little [ __ ]
crazy to be a professional you gotta be
a little crazy to do it be an actor I
think but definitely like yeah well look
man it sound like I'd watch this even if
you weren't it sounds really cool and if
there is a cool part that they haven't
cast something you know your buddy
Rosenbaum listen the only reason I said
I wouldn't say it but it sounds like
something I'd like so if there's
something even if it's a cool little
character part or whatever I can go
stash you know Ross - are you gonna
wrestle oh no I wouldn't wrestle
wouldn't be a good I don't think your
neck is no no no I wouldn't want to get
that big but I could easily be
somebody's brother or a manager or some
guy who drives a pickup truck who's like
you there's a lot of things I could do
character and fun something works like
two days a week you know I got yeah it's
easy Monsieur midnight busting is yeah
no no sure two days two days a week
except it's gonna be those two days
gonna be first up Monday morning and
last up Friday night so what but it
sounds fun to keep that in mind have you
ever shot in Georgia yeah yeah I did a
week for guardians to there and I shot I
think I shoot this Bruce Willis thing I
this independent movie I did I don't
know no justjust guardians I think there
I am not a lot I mean I I grew up with
five hours from there like in Indiana
okay sours yeah you know that area I
found my apartment there and they they I
mean I was gonna get it anyway but they
pitched it to me that that there was a
guy doing a Marvel show there right now
like that [ __ ] matters to me I don't
know why I don't know who it is oh
really
oh I'll Steve I'll take it that guy's
doing it anyway also you know I I
definitely I think it'd be fun to work
with you you look like somebody just be
a good time to work with I think we'd
have fun I like having a good time when
I work yeah you know me too well I don't
care about being the Lee I never get
mean I'm not the lead often but I never
really I want to go and have fun yeah I
want to have a good time on set when
people are looking to have fun and get
the work done and be the best they could
be and be supportive that's the best
thing in the world to be a part of you
know what it comes to heels I was the I
was
the first person cast and I think I'll
be the first person in the in the
credits but that shows only gonna work
if everyone works if everyone works and
it's an ensemble if we don't get some
it's gonna be tough for us to to to sort
of find a niche in the marketplace if if
we don't get some characters that really
pop like do you watch success and
success succession succession I heard
watch that you watch their own I've seen
a couple episodes yeah it's like you
know they've got they've got great
characters and the leads on on that show
are great but if you don't have a cousin
Greg who just comes out and pops and
it's just constantly funny and right and
as and as the and it's saying the lines
that people are quoting at the
watercooler the next day if that's
actually still an expression I think
people still know what it means but I
don't think there's water coolers
anymore if you don't have those
characters and we've got a couple a
couple of the of the mid card wrestlers
that should really pop really yeah oh
that's good hopefully it sounds like fun
man very colorful
yeah well I'm excited look this has been
great thank you for coming back
especially after you know the first half
this is the first time I've ever like
had to have someone come back finish and
we can kind of go talk about what that
what had happened so it's gonna be
interesting yeah I'm honored and you
live down here
I live here now a member of where I
remember we won't talk about that but we
can go there and hang out sometime yeah
you know it's right around the corner
watch a I saw you there once watch a
like posh it's a nice restaurant and
also when you're and you're coming back
you don't you said you wouldn't do
another podcast before mine when you're
done with he'll so we could talk about I
don't know if I said I mean I'll do one
in between now and then but when it
comes time I just said when the show
comes it comes time to promote heals
I'll come back yeah so keep going your
keep growing your subscriber base how do
you measure I'm curious about it's like
I no no no no when you do it when you do
a podcast today did these various
platforms are they pretty good at
reporting back to you like well you have
a problem you could check out you know I
I could look every day of like our
numbers how we're growing what we did
this month which each guest does so it's
very important to you know to get people
to subscribe to listen to and yeah and
it's also hard because you know I'm not
a huge star
but you know your guests if you have a
good guest somebody that people want to
listen to and then if they like the
guest you're hoping then they start
liking you and then people start
listening and going hey I can't wait to
hear what rose and mom's gonna say
harass for what he's gonna get out of
this guest or what I'm gonna get out of
this guest yeah I mean I listen to the
daily because I like the way that
Michael Bob ro is able to talk about
complex subjects but asks the questions
that I think you know no one wants to
ask well not not that no one wants to
ask actually he asked the question that
people that are probably his level of
intelligence think are beneath them
right but he understands something
complex like I'm not [ __ ] about Syria I
didn't know anything about Syria but
when he does a podcast that's 25 minutes
long that talks about the basis for said
conflict in Syria and why it might be
problematic for the United States to
just pull her troops out of there I feel
like a walk away going oh I know I know
something so I listened to it for him in
the way that he goes about a subject as
opposed to just listening to it because
I'm interested in tournaments
I hear that tonight yes I would actually
listen to that I think from me it's more
like you know what can I do
what do I offer I think what I offer is
sheer panic sure panic I think it's I
think what people want is like they go
to late-night they see late-night
television it's just like I'll Stephen
Amell on arrow and you make a few jokes
and you go when you're in your suit
you're nice yeah but when they can get
inside somebody go hey this this is like
a real conversation between two human
beings it's not like oh he's a big actor
he's and the more people open up the
more people talk about their life and
their [ __ ]
it just it I think it helps universally
I think it helps the world I think it's
you know you know other otherwise if
there what if there was if you weren't
on this no one would know about your
panic attack no no oh they think he's
indestructible okay he's a real-life
superhero
he doesn't have problems and I think it
helps normalize that and I've said that
a million times what was the name of the
guy that you brought up that's if that's
a friend of yours that had done
background work on arrow that Troy Troy
yeah Troy I mean you know that's I know
that you thought that maybe I got stuck
on that to sort of bring it back to the
beginning of the process that
last year but weeks ago well sure but
last year but it actually makes me
pretty happy that somebody like Troy
might might have thought that I was a
dink and then listens to the podcast and
it helps it helps change an opinion I'm
not out I'm not out to change opinions
but I don't understand how anything but
the long-form conversation is what
people want to hear now right I just
want to get to know you you listen Dane
Cook I think I talked about I know it's
a prime example many people all that
guys it's kind of an [ __ ] all right
yeah guys how do you know he's not of
course had him on the podcast I talked
to him for now we talked about this
stuff and afterwards I know all my
listeners were immediately like love
this guy
yep he's a great guy because you don't
know anyone so when Troy's on set and he
hears I don't want this is happening why
cuz he didn't pay extra attention to
someone or 8in yeah he wasn't oh he
looked like he was in 10 sunset maybe
was preparing for the world there's so
many variables that you just cannot
judge anyone you don't know what they're
going through
mm-hmm you know I mean Brian could have
when you walked out gone God that guy's
a [ __ ] mess it sounds like Ryan was
really despondent well I just don't
think he's ever experienced stuff like
that that's why when I ask him questions
he gives me three words or a couple of
multisite I'm monitoring levels layoffs
it'd be weird I've never I've never been
in the presence of someone that is that
sort of went through what what I went
through but I I imagine that that would
have been a weird thing and a slightly
stressful thing to see I think I that I
I knew what was going on I didn't
there's some reason I don't know what it
is but I don't freak out when people
have [ __ ] going on for some reason
there's something in my mind or my brain
maybe it's my gift seriously this is my
Saints maybe sounds like I'm a god-like
person and I'm [ __ ] not all I'm
saying is that maybe that was my gift
just sort of like when someone's
freaking out or pukes all over a floor
or I go into emergency mode and calm the
person down mode and I just want to help
somebody yeah I just feel it's going on
I don't want to be like oh my god oh I
never that guy who's gonna look like
there
now appear to be freaking out I'm there
honestly because I think I can help you
that's how I feel that probably feels
pretty good it does it feels good I felt
like hey you know he's leaving he's
getting up there he's made a decision
but I'm like hey I'm cool with that I
just wanted to be safe I wanna get
better and followed up you made sure I
got home texted my wife you know didn't
know you had a number but whatever yeah
that's something dude I love you this
that's it let's take some pictures and
get out of here all right man thanks for
having me back thanks dude
all right buddy well there you have it
that was Stephen Amell Stephen again I
thank you from the bottom of my heart
for coming in this is the kind of stuff
that I want to talk about this is the
kind of stuff that is real and I can't
say it enough that do kudos he could
have easily said [ __ ] off I don't want
to do it I'll do it when I feel better
don't hear any of this and that would've
been fine but I'm glad that he chose to
allow you to hear it made me feel like
holy [ __ ] I just wish I would have
spoken up sooner you know if this
podcast was out before I was doing him
pastor I would probably been more
vulnerable more open to allowing people
one of my feelings and then in my mind
but you do feel like God I'm the I'm a
producer on this show I'm the lead I you
don't want people to think you're not
strong isn't that stupid isn't it okay
to not be strong sometimes it's okay to
just be vulnerable and let things happen
and just kind of give yourself a break
totally it is you saw me were you at
Thanksgiving I was not you were not he I
had a breakdown in front of my friends
because my grandpa passed away on
Thanksgiving and I remember everybody
went around and said thanks for
everything and I of course they ended
with me and I couldn't keep my [ __ ]
together and I really tried that I don't
cry in front of people I really do not
cry I'm starting to say you know what
[ __ ] it if I feel emotional if something
hits me I'm gonna cry for a second I'm
gonna let it out I think it's important
and I cried I looked up and there's
everyone else just crying which helped
me and I think it's nice I think it's
it's important just be honest with
yourself and honest with everyone else
like hey you know I'm not comfortable
right now
I'm trying to act like nothing's going
on but I having a panic attack and I
don't know what to do
maybe there's a doctor that can help me
maybe someone else here has an idea but
get me through this and then there's not
that weight on you that you have to you
know you have to go back and finish the
scene you're like hey let's do it in
pieces and are you okay now let's let's
just work this out together and okay is
it embarrassing know what son it
shouldn't be it's like hey this is life
let's help our fellow man out hey I want
to give a shout out to these patrons
these beautiful patrons they are they
put a lot of money into patreon and I
really appreciate it
Leah s Barry I Dion K Lauren G Jill E
Robert B Jason W Angelina G Kevin R
Tricia Nancy D Nancy Bobby B Niko P
Yukiko
Yukiko that's such a great name Yukiko
Jerry W Taylor B emily sarah v MH board
Tex thank you guys so much
also the wine the wine pure evil wine is
out so get a subscription
knocking point that's also Stephens
company Welling and I made a new one
since our wine sold out we're gonna keep
getting you great guests I can't thank
you enough Thank You Ryan Tazz who's my
engineer who's here who's just makes me
feel better about life oh great yeah I
hoped you liked the questions I asked
Steven the [ __ ] talkin I hope we're
making this show better and stronger
what you can do is just get your folks
get your friends to subscribe
let's go out in this song Mia I like
this song tears it's from left on Laurel
this one is called let's go for a ride
[Music]
Sam you tried uh so I'm told
feels like wasted hope now I
I got plenty of time
wasn't supposed to amount to much
banana said too much think I'm falling
apart right
get myself together tell me
crazies are coming through
right your name
[Music]